[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est palaleo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux dernière Paléo news de l'année
on va faire ça détente on va faire ça
relaxe c'est les vacances on va pas
parler de sujets qui font polémique on
va pas parler d'actualité qui donne qui
donne pas le smile on va rester léger et
pour commencer léger pourquoi ne pas
commencer par le plus gros pliosaur
jamais découvert jusqu'à présent
nouvelle annoncé dans la BBC enfin par
la BBC euh un pliosaure donc vous voyez
le crâne ici un crâne qui fait quasiment
2 m de longe si on en croit ce qui a été
ce qui a été rendu publique jusqu'à
présent alors ça n'a pas été publié dans
la littérature scientifique c'est la
première chose qu'il faut dire à propos
de ce crâne de pliosaur avant même de
parler de ce que ça pourrait rajouter
scientifiquement parlant à nos
connaissances c'est que bah pour
l'instant on nen sait rien en réalité
parce que il a pas été publié
scientifiquement il y a documentaire qui
va apparaître en janvier avec David
àamboro donc qui va être qui va être
rendu publicique en en janvier mais bon
l'histoire nous a appris que il fallait
se méfier de ces découvertes qui ont été
annoncées dans des documentaire avant
d'être annoncé dans la littérature
scientifique euh si vous voyez mon
regard se diriger tout droit vers
Netflix n'est-ce pas
euh voilà j'ai j'ai j'ai un petit j'ai
un petit pincep de M sence face à ce
documentaire parce que justement ben
déjà on nous annonce des grandes
découvertes scientifiques dans les
médias avant de nous l'annoncer dans la
revue dans les revues scientifiques ce
qui veut dire que tout ce que vous allez
voir dans ce document enfin rien au
contraire rien de ce que vous allez voir
dans ce documentaire n'aura été passé au
crible de la revue par les
Pères et par exemple vous voyez le la
première chose que je redoute enfin la
première chose qui semble confirmer mes
craintes c'est si vous regardez un petit
peu ce museau c'est le museau de cet
animal ici je vous ai même trouvé une
petite photo avec un zoom regardez la
beauté de ce fossile regardez la beauté
de ses dents oui mais c'est pas comme ça
que le fossile a été découvert le
fossile il faisait cette gueule là quand
ils l'ont découvert et c'est confirmé
dans cette vidéo de la BBC où justement
ils font la pub de leur documentaire à
venir vous avez donc des des gros
planans sur le crâne tel qu'il a été
présenté dans les médias avec on voit
très très bien voyez ces énormes dents
magnifique mais voici la vidéo qu'ils
ont tourné le jour de la
découverte et ces dents n'existent pas
sur le fossile original ces dents ces
dents c'est c'est du rajouter c'est
c'est pas ce n'était pas là à la base
alors le le reste du fossile a été
exploité à même la falaise ça c'est le
morceau qui était tombé donc c'est le
bout du museau qui était tombé et le
reste comme vous voyez ici a été
exploité à même la falaise donc je ne je
ne doute pas que le reste de ces chic
donc ceux qui sont pas sur le museau
voyez ceux qui sont au niveau des des
mâchoires ici là je ne doute pas que ces
Chico eu soi réellement là mais il y a
quand même d'ors et déjà voyez là ce que
je redoute c'est que tous ces Chico là
soi faux et ceux qui sont là soi vrai
voilà et donc à ce niveau-là bah on voit
déjà des petites accommodations avec la
réalité voyez il y a y a deux trois de
trois petits aménagements de la réalité
qui ont été fait pour ce doc comaire
avant même la publication scientifique
du spécimen j'ai des craintes j'ai des
craintes mais oui effectivement ce si
tout cela se confirme bel et bien nous
serions face au pliosaur le plus grand
jamais découvert puisque chronosaurus a
un crâne d'à peu près 1,60 à M70 je
crois de long celui-là si on en croit
encore une fois ce qui est sorti dans la
dans la presse mais c'est pas de la
littértion c'est pas de la littérature
scientifique la presse il aurait un
crâne d'à peu près 2 m de long ce que je
suis prêt à croire étant donné euh ce
qu'on voit là voyez l'échelle du crâne
par rapport à à ces messieurs dames je
veux bien croire qu'il app proche les 2
m de long ceci étant dit bon après c'est
peut-être la caméra qui déforme mais là
si je vois le en imaginant le monsieur
s'allonger à côté de la bestiol j'ai du
mal à voir ce crâne être plus long que
le monsieur là et le monsieur là et s'il
est un humain normalement constitué il
fait entre 1,60 et 1,80 enfin
normalement dans la moyenne j'entends
hein c'est vous n'êtes pas à normal si
vous faites 1,90 quoi
que si on en croit les gens qui qui qui
font la théorie du complot des géants
les gens qui font plus d'un,90
descendent d'une race d'Atlante ou je
sais pas quoi mais bref je je m'égare je
on verra on verra la littérature
scientifique je ça sent le soufflet qui
va retomber moi voilà ma mon pronostic
quand la publication scientifique
arrivera c'est que ça sent le soufflet
qui va retomber ça sent le crâne qui au
final sera pas si grand que ça pas qui
fera pas les 2 mètres annoncés qui fera
peut-être 1,70 1,80 le faisant le
rendant équivalent du coup à
chronosaurus et donc ce serait pas le
plus grand pliosaur jamais découvert ce
qui ne changerait pas à la beauté de la
découverte soyons tout à fait honnête le
problème un autre problème que je vois
se profiler à l'horizon c'est que ce
monsieur qui est donc le découvreur du
fossile n'est pas n'est pas
paléontologue rattaché à un institut de
recherche c'est un amateur enfin c'est
un collectionneur du coup est-ce que le
fossile du coup va rester dans sa
collection privée s'il s'agit d'une
nouvelle espèce et ça a l'air d'être le
cas parce que là cette crête sagittale
ici apparemment c'est unique parmi les
pliosaures donc ça aurait tendance à
suggérer que ce truc est une nouvelle
espèce donc est-ce que c'est s'il s'agit
réellement d'une nouvelle espèce est-ce
que du coup on va faire une entorse à la
règle qui veut que les nouvelles espèces
doivent finir dans des institutions
publiques et est-ce que ça va rester du
coup dans la collection privée de ce
monsieur je ne sais pas mais vous voyez
il y a déjà au moins deux raisons de
dire que ça sent le le soufflet qui va
retomber quelque chose de bien mais on
attend de voir du coup bah le
documentaire et on attend de voir euh
bah une publication scientifique on
l'espère bon donc du coup on en
reparlera c'est à peu près certain qu'on
en reparlera de celui-là euh et puis
ouais pour information il aurait 150
millions d'années Jurassique supérieur
donc de l'Oxfordien en tout cas c'est si
on en croit les les dates qui ont été
données encore une fois dans les médias
oxfordien c'est c'est cohérent avec le
fait que ça a été retrouvé dans les
falaises euh de de de d'Angleterre quoi
voilà donc on attend du nouveau à propos
de ce de ce de ce pliosaur qui bah on
l'espère ne sera pas une déception on
espère que ce sera pas une déception
mais de toute façon une déception ça en
est déjà une puisque on vient de se
faire souffler le titre du plus gros
pliosaure mesdames et messieurs ce
pliosaure de la BBC à quelques jours
d'intervalle nous a soufflé le titre de
de plus gros pliosaur non j'en rajoute
un petit peu mais quand même la revue
Scientific reports donc une une des des
revues attachées à nature une revue
prestigieuse venait de publier quelques
semaines auparavant un nouveau
pliosaure du Jurassique de France de
laoren et il s'appelle du coup
l'orenosaurus lorenosaurus ici vous
voyez son son petit nom ici
l'orenosaurus
keni venait tout juste d'être décrit sur
la base de de jolis fragments comme vous
pouvez voir et notamment une mandibule
complète mandibule complète qui
rivalise qui isait en taille du coup
avec parmi les plus grands pliosaures
connus regardez la gigantisme de cette
mandibule la barre d'échelle à 10 cm les
tailles ici donc elle est la
mandibule avec une une longueur de 1 M30
à
1,50 faisait de l'orénosaurus un
pliosaure plus grand que simolestè Don
dont la mandibule fera fait un peu moins
d'un MT et à peu près aussi grand
légèrement moins grand que méga
cepalosaurus donc la méga grosse tête
c'est c'est plutôt clair comme nom à
1,70 et donc chronosaurus qui qui est à
peu près par là aussi quoi chronosaurus
qui est à peu près par là aussi donc még
céphalosaurus et chronosaurus
continueent de se battre toujours pour
le plus gros crâne on verra ce que
deviendra ce ce nouveau pliosaur
découvert et annoncé par la BBC dont je
viens de parler mais en tout cas ouais
on avait on avait euh on commençait à
avoir euh un un contestant au titre quoi
regardez ce cette beauté là on av on
avait un un prétendant au titre de plus
grands pliosaur et on se l' fait
souffler en moins en moins de quelques
semaines quoi c'est c'est rageant c'est
super rageant mais cette étude
heureusement elle ne fait pas que
présenter
l'orenosaurus qui d'ailleurs date du
milieu du Jurassique hein du bajoien
donc il est un peu plus vieux quand même
que celui annoncé par la BBC euh un
petit peu plus vieux de d'une d'une
vingtaine de millions d'années on est à
160 millions d'années à peu près on est
tout en haut du bageocien donc peut-être
un peu moins de 70 170 millions million
d'années et ce laorénosaurus donc il est
accompagné d'une étude plutôt
intéressante des dents et de la
diversité dentaire chez les chez les
pliosaures et c'est ce qui est résumé
ici sur ce graphe alors c'est un peu
c'est un peu c'est un peu péchu comme
façon de présenter les choses mais en
gros euh vous avez ces deux axes
vertical horizontal qui vous
représentent la diversité morphologique
euh dans une unité complètement
arbitraire que je que vous n'avez pas
besoin de comprendre pour comprendre le
graphe c'est qu'en gros plus un ensemble
de points prend de la place sur le
grafhe plus vous avez de la diversité
alimentaire parce que c'est quelque
chose qui a été fait sur les dents c'est
une étude qui a été faite sur les dents
des pliosaures donc ce qui représente
techniquement la diversité alimentaire
euh donc ça peut être du poisson ça peut
être d'autres d'autres vertébrés euh
plus grands je veux dire hein comme les
comme des tortues par exemple ou ça peut
être bah des des bélimnites ou des
amonites ou des voilà d'autres animaux
des des des animaux complètement mous
mou aussi ça peut être des pieuvres donc
en fonction de si vous mangez des trucs
complètement mou vous ou des trucs
avecun colonne vertébrale ou des trucs
avec une coquille comme des amonites
vous allez pas avoir la même morphologie
dentaire vous imaginez bien que pour
écraser des amonites il faut des dents
bien rondes alors que pour attraper des
des des petits des petits poupes
vachement glissants il faut avoir des
des dents plutôt très pointu comme des
harpons quoi pointu et crrainel comme
des harpon donc tout ça ça va reffléter
sur l'anatomie dentaire et donc ce qu'il
faut voir sur ce graphe en réalité c'est
que plus ça plus un groupement prend de
la place dans ces deux axes prend de
occupe de la surface entre ces deux axes
plus la
diversité des dents et donc la diversité
de régime alimentaire est grande et ce
qu'on voit c'est que bah au début de
leur évolution ici les pliosaures
occupent un petit espace et que cet
espace s'agrandit d'abord à la fin du
Jurassique ici avec ce triangle puis
encore plus au au au Crétacé donc c'est
ce qu'on voit là c'est le le le le truc
hyper transparent qu'on voit à l'arrière
là mais au Crétacé ça occupe encore plus
de place donc il y a cet article il met
aussi en évidence la diversification des
pliosaures et donc ce nouveau pliosaure
l'orénosaurus augmente quand même pas
mal la diversité de nos de nos
pliosaures de nos tout premiers
pliosaures du début du début milieu
jurassique on reste dans le Mésozoïque
avec l'Afrique du Sud maintenant ou des
empreintes ou cette étude publiée dans
plus one euh révèle des empreintes
beaucoup d'empreintes qui qu'on trouve
dans le Trias de le Trias supérieur
d'Afrique du Sud donc des empreintes qui
appartiennent enfin d'Afrique du Sud du
sud de l'Afrique devrais-je dire parce
que c'est c'est le lesoto en
l'occurrence euh mais c'est vrai que
Afrique du Sud Afrique australe c'est
c'est c'est Afrique australe c'est
chiant à dire donc je préfère dire
Afrique du Sud mais l'Afrique du Sud
c'est le nom du pays donc c'est le nom
d'un pays mais oui c'est l'Afrique
australe et euh plus particulièrement
donc le lesésoto et dans donc dans ce
lesuto on a des empreintes qui
appartiennent à certains des plus
anciens dinosaures du monde et notamment
on a des empreintes qui ont des
proportions au niveau des doigts qui
suggèrent que peut-être ça
appartiendrait à des oiseaux alors c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant c'est
d'autant plus intéressant en réalité que
on avait déjà des possibles empreintes
d'oiseaux qui avait été découvert dans
l'éangien en France l'éangien des causes
du Larzac qui nous avait donné euh des
empreintes de possibles oiseaux aussi
euh les tangiens c'est le tout début du
Jurassique bon le problème c'est que ces
empreinte d'oiseau du la fin du Trias de
l'Afrique australe du leszoto euh n'ont
pas de 4è doigt parce que vous voyez la
différence entre des empreintes d'oiseau
et des empreintes de dinosaures c'est
que bah les empreintes de dinosaures ont
toujours trois doigts alors que sauf si
elles sont très très très profond et
dans ce cas-là le le petit ergo là
qu'ils ont à l'arrière va s'imprimer
dans la boue mais il faut vraiment que
l'empreinte soit très très profonde mais
généralement les empreintes de
dinosaures n'ont que trois doigts enfin
le dinosaure teréropode j'entends
évidemment venez pas me parler de
diplodocus on n'est pas
là mais les empreintes d'oiseau elles
normalement ont quatre doigts si vous
regardez n'importe quelle empreinte des
oiseaux qui sont relativement volants
évidemment parce que les oiseaux
coureurs ont trois doigts voir deux pour
les autruches mais en gros ouais c'est
la différence majeur entre l'empreinte
de dinosaure moyenne et l'empreinte
d'oiseau moyenne c'est la présence de ce
4è doigt regarder les empreintes de
pigeon par exemple il y a un 4è doigt
parce que les oiseaux ont redéveloppé
cette espèce d'Ergo que dont je parlais
tout à l'heure pour attraper les
branches ça leur donne
une la capacité d'agriper comme ça donc
ce ce qu ce 4è doigt qui est en réalité
le premier c'est le pouce enfin c'est le
gros orteil s'imprime normalement dans
la boue quand vous avez des des
empreintte d'oiseau donc là on n pas ce
4e doigt donc c'est difficile quand même
d'être sûr que qu'il il s'agit
d'empreinte d'oiseaux et du coup d'où le
nom aussi d'où le fait qu'ils utilisent
le mot birdlike donc ça ressemble à des
oiseaux mais en réalité on ne peut pas
dire que ce sont des empreintes
d'oiseaux mais si ces empreintes
birdlike appartiennent bel et bien à des
oiseaux alors ce serait les plus anciens
fossiles d'oiseau datant du Trias hein
du coup du Trias supérieur c'est-à-dire
bah de l'époque où justement les les
analyses génétiques place l'origine des
oiseaux parce que les analyses
génétiques des oiseaux modernes et des
crocodiles place la racine évolutive des
oiseaux au Trias en réalité pas au
Jurassique le premier fossile d'oiseau
c'est toujours ça reste encore
aujourd'hui archéoptérix euh 150
millions d'années du coup au Jurassique
mais normalement on devrait trouver des
fossiles d'oiseau jusqu'au Trias mais on
ne les trouve pas et donc peut-être que
ces empreintes birdlike si elles
appartiennent effectivement à des
oiseaux pourrai être les traces de ces
tout premiers oiseaux qui qui sont
apparus et donc peut-être qu' aussi en
France du coup c'est ces empreintes
qu'on a euh dans dans dans le Larzac
pourrai être elle aussi des empreintes
d'oiseaux et la différence entre les
empreintes qu'on a au dans le Larzac au
début du jurassiic et ces empreintes du
sud de l'Afrique c'est que celles qu'on
a dans le Larzac elles elles ont un 4è
doigt bah peut-être peut-être qu'on a
des oiseaux jusque dans le Jurassique et
jusque dans le Jurassique inférieur et
peut-être même jusqu'au triace supérieur
mais bon bah on attend de trouver les
squelettes hein il nous faut il nous
faut des squelettes donc du coup on est
sur des découvertes qui posent encore
plus de questions et qui nous forc à
aller chercher encore plus de fossiles
oh comme c'est
dommage allez à la recherche des des des
squelettes des premiers oiseaux mais
évidemment la nouvelle qui a fait le
plus de bruit pendant ce mois de
décembre ça a été la publication dans la
prestigieuse revue Science
advances d'un juvénil de Gorgosaurus
nous provenant d'Amérique du Nord de de
la fin du Crétacé d'Amérique du Nord
publié par des grands noms de de la
paléontologie des des tyranosauridé hein
Ericson et Philippe Curri entre autres
entre autres grands noms et ce ce
Gorgosaurus alors Gorgosaurus c'est qui
déjà hein c'est un tyrannosauridé c'est
un
tyrannosauridé un petit peu plus petit
que tyrannosaur c'est c'est ce qu'on
peut faire de plus Tyrannosaurus sans
être Tyrannosaurus quoi en gros hein
c'est plus ou moins ça euh mais sa
biologie était très très similaire à
Tyrannosaurus et la raison pour laquelle
il est tout petit sur cette image ici là
çaêtre reconstitution bah c'est parce
que le spécimen décrit dans cet article
est un juvénile et ce n'est pas
n'importe quel juvénil de
Gorgosaurus ce Gorgosaurus c'est un
juvénil qui a un contenu stomacal
préservé euh dans sa région abdominale
alors ce contenu stomacal comment on
sait que c'est un contenu stomacal et
pas juste des ossements voyez dispersés
au au 80 et qui ont fini par coup de bol
à cet endroit-là bah parce que sur sa
surface vous voyez il y a ces ces
petites vaguelettes ici que vous voyez
là ce sont des c'est de la dissolution
dû à l'acide de l'estomac des du
Gorgosaurus savoir que c'était des
broyurs doos les
tyranosauridés donc ça c'était capable
de tout digérer et contrairement au
rapace
moderne il y a tout qui passait au
travers ça recrachait pas les EAU les
les tyrannosauridés ça tout passait au
travers on a d'ailleurs des des crottes
he de tyranos de tyrannosauridé qui
contiennent des petits morceaux de d'os
broyé et à moitié dissous voilà qui
montre très bien que tout était digéré
qu'il ne recrachait pas il ne faisait
pas de pelote de réjection contrairement
à ce que font les rapasses modernes
donc on a ce contenu stomacal confirmé
d'un Gorgosaurus juvénil contenu
stomacal qui se compose de deux paires
de jambes puisque vous voyez ici qu'il y
a un tibiia deux tibias trois tibias
donc s'il y a trois tibias c'est qu'il y
a au moins deux paires de jambes hein
euh vous voyez ici donc il y a même deux
fémures de ce côté-là donc on a deux on
a une paire de jambes ici en vert et
deux tibias ici donc une paire de jambes
ici en bleu et qui devait appartenir à
deux petits dinosaures qui s'appellent
des
kenagiatidés les kenagiatidés du genre
cpitè qui sont un peu comme des
oviraptors quoi si vous voulez savoir à
quoi ça ressemble ça ressemble à des
petits oviraptors à peu près et
qu'est-ce que tout ça nous apprend bah
déjà ça nous apprend des choses sur ce
que mangeent Gorgosaurus et notamment ce
que mangaient les Gorgosaurus juvéniles
parce que figurez-vous que euh il y a
des hypothèses qui s'affrontent et ces
hypothèses ces hypothèses qui
s'affrontent c'est celle que soit les
Gorgosaurus euh chasser avec leurs
momentom et leurs popos et du coup
manger des grosses proies quand ils
étaient juvéniles hein du moins
j'entends euh il mangeaent les grosses
proies avec du coup le reste d'une
petite meute hein donc il chassait en
meute et il y a la théorie qui consiste
à dire que euh les Gorgosaurus juvénils
occupaient l'espace écologique qui
nétait était occupé par aucune autre
espèce puisque à l'époque au Crétacé il
n'y a que des petits chasseurs comme les
droméosaures et de très grands chasseurs
comme les adultes les tyrannosaures
adultes et il y a pas vraiment de
d'espèce entre les deux qui occupent
l'espace de chasseurs de taille moyenne
et donc il y a l'hypothèse qui consiste
à dire que peut-être en réalité c'estes
juvéniles de tyrannosaures comme ce
Gorgosaurus occupaient cet espace
écologique cette niche écologique de
chasseurs de taille moyenne et bien là
nous avons devant nous euh une preuve
qui soutient l'hypothèse la l'hypothèse
numéro 2 celle que notre Gorgosaurus
chassa seul des proies de taille moyenne
donc sachant que des proies de petite
taille ça va être des lézards ou des
petits oiseaux par exemple là ce sont
des proies de taille moyenne et il
devait les chasser seul pourquoi bah
parce que elles sont trop petites pour
avoir été partagées avec d'autres
d'autres individus vous imaginez bien
que dans tous ces documentaires où vous
voyez et c'est devenu absolument partout
hein maintenant dans tous les
documentaires ce que vous voyez c'est un
tyrannosaure adulte et deux
tyrannosaures juvénils je je ne compte
plus le nombre de documentaires où on
voit ça mais un tyrannosaure adulte deux
tyrannosaures juvénils et les juvénils
font rabatteur pour le tyrannosaur
adulte c'est c'était déjà là dans c'est
c'est un truc qu'on voyait déjà dans Sur
la terre des dinosaures et qu'on voit
encore aujourd'hui par exemple dans
préhistorique planète ou dans le
documentaire Netflix dont on a parlé
récemment c'est devenu omniprésent comme
théorie bien sachez mesdames et
Messieurs que ça reposait sur du rien
c'était une hypothèse c'était vraiment
juste une théorie qui avait été un peu
jetée comme ça euh euh sans trop de
preuve et donc là on a une preuve
physique que un tyrannosaure juvénil de
taille moyenne s'en est pris à des
petits animaux des animaux qui en
réalité étaient trop petits pour avoir
été partagés c'est exactement ce qu'ils
disent dans l'article donc je je je ne
l'invente pas voilà c'est écrit juste
ici là découv ouverte la découverte
présente même si ce n'est qu'un seul
spécimen nous révèle que le petit
Gorgosaurus ce petit Gorgosaurus a
chassé seul des proies de petite taille
car elles étaient trop petites pour être
partagées par des conss spécifiques donc
des des membres de son
espèce maintenant vous pouvez faire les
hypothèses à dooc que vous voulez pour
continuer à essayer de sauver la théorie
de la chasse en meut he la théorie des
rabatteurs vous pouvez faire des
hypothèses à dooc genre on n' pas la
preuve qu'il y avait pas d'adulte avec
eux ou on n' pas la preuve qu'il y avait
pas d'autres tyrannosaures juvénil avec
avec lui bon ceci étant dit il y a pas
de trace de de dents de tyrannosauridé
adulte sur ses eau donc on peut quand
même avec une certaine confiance faire
l'hypothèse que il y avait pas de
tyrannosaure adulte avec ce juvénil
puisque il y a pas de trace de dents de
de tyrannosaur adulte dessus mais
combien d'hypothèses adoc êtes-vous
capable adoc ça veut dire basé sur du
vent hein c'est pour qu'on soit bien
d'accord combien d'hypothèses basé sur
du vent vous allez être capable de me
sortir dans les commentaires pour
continuer à sauver la chasse en
meut ça je suis curieux je suis curieux
ou alors ça veut juste dire que on s'est
fait nourrir de documentaires qui nous
racontaent des choses sorti nulle part
ou en tout cas sorti de qui n'était que
des théories et qui attendaient qu'on
découvre des preuve pour les étayer ou
les disqualifier ceci mesdames et
messieurs est une preuve qui va plutôt
dans le sens de la disqualification le
principe de parsimonie l'hypothèse la
plus parsimonieuse c'est que jusqu'à
preuve du contraire il y avait pas un
autre animal là parce qu'il y a une très
bonne raison de penser qu'il y avait pas
d'autres animaux ici c'est que les
justement les proies sont trop petites
et à l'inverse il y a aucune raison de
penser qu'il y avait d'autres animaux
avec lui le principe de parciimonie
impose le l'économie d'hypothèse et
l'économie d'hypothèse ici c'est
l'économie de
d'acteurs
d'acteurs pour lesquels on na pas de
preuve qu'ils étai là quand ceci s'est
produit bon tout ça étant évidemment
établi que il faut partir du principe
qu'il chassait que ce n'a pas que ces
restes ici n'ont pas été
charrogniés quelles sont les choses qui
pourraient nous faire penser que ces
éléments n'ont pas été charogniés bon
déjà parce qu'on sait que tyran que les
tyranosauridés de manière générale
chassaient on a maintenant quand même
pas mal de preuves par ailleurs que les
tyranos que les tyrannosauridés
chassaient et n'étaient pas que
charoniard ceci dit ça n'exclut pas que
ces restes là en particulier é été
charronnier ce qui suggère que ça a pas
été charonnier c'est que bah ce sont des
cuisses là si vous voyez les
reconstructions les reconstructions qui
sont faites ici voilà c'est c'est les B
c'est les bons cuissaux charnus là qui
ont été bouffés pas pas les parties
cracra boudin avec plein d'os comme la
tête voilà les côtes les vertèbres voilà
bon il y a un petit bout de queue quand
même c'est un morceau CCRA la queue mais
mais voilà c'est c'est quand même des
morceaux c'est c'est quand même des bons
cuissaux quoi des bouts de choix j'ai
envie de qualifier ça donc il est
possible que voilà ça ça veut dire que
ce Gorgosaurus il était le premier sur
la scène en fait les les charogniards
généralement il leur reste pas des bons
cuissaux comme ça à manger bon il s'est
quand même enfilé toute la guibol donc
c'est pas impossible non plus que il
soit arrivé après la bataille et ce soit
enfilé les guboles entières alors qu'il
y avait plus tellement de viande dessus
ça c'est vrai donc il faut admettre
quand même que ça a été chassé et pas
charonniier mais si on admet que ça a
été chassé alors la chasse en solo reste
est l'hypothèse la plus partimonieuse et
ça c'est quand même vachement
intéressant et du coup ça veut dire et
du coup ça confirmerait l'hypothèse que
les G enfin les tyrannosaures juvénils
les tyrannosauridé juvéniles
remplissaient la niche écologique des
chasseurs de taille moyenne dans leur
environnement où il n'y avait pas de
chasseurs de taille moyenne à part des
tyrannosaures juvénils ce qui était
quand même pas une mauvaise théorie hein
vous vous en conviendrez donc c'est un
fossile qui est très très intéressant et
je vous invite à aller lire cet article
parce que il remet du coup pas mal de
choses en question et je vous invite
aussi aller voir ma vidéo sur les
teropodes ne chassez pas en meut si vous
ne l'avez jamais vu parce que j'ai fait
45 minutes de vidéo pour expliquer qu'on
avait zéro preuve que les thopotes
chassé en meut par ailleurs bon si on
parle de tyrannosaur on parle de
Jurassic Park ou on parle pas de
Jurassic Park bon et si on parle de
Jurassic Park bah on parle de moustique
dans l'ambre et oui et oui Mesdames et
Messieurs le plus vieux moustique dans
l'ambre découvert dans l'embre du Liban
daté du Crétacé inférieur je vais vous
montrer la petite frise chronologique
voilà libanoculex littéralement le
moustique du Liban du Crétacé inférieur
mais surtout le plus vieux moustique Mâ
le plus vieux moustique Mâ parce que
quand on regarde sa petite tête là voyez
ici notre moustique ici et ben il a des
grand grandes antennes plumeuses et ces
grandes antennes plumeuses là qu'on voit
très très bien ici ça c'est typique des
moustiques Mâ c'est ils se servent de
leur grandes antennes plumeuses pour
capter les féromones des des femelles
justement mais par contre ce qu'il y a
de marrant c'est que notre moustique
malâle il a aussi un rostre piqueur donc
il a le petit appareil qui lui sert à à
pomper du sang et ça c'est pas banal
chez les moustiques parce que
normalement vous savez que chez les
moustiques c'est les femelles qui
pompent le sang elles font un repas de
sang afin de pouvoir faire des œufs
enfin de pouvoir apporter du du de la
nourriture pour leurs œufs là on a un
moustique malâ du Crétacé qui nous
indique que les moustiques mal du
Crétacé ils pompaient du sang aussi en
tout cas ils avaient au moins
l'appareillage pour pomper du sang ça
veut pas dire qu'il le faisait forcément
d'autant que vous pouvez voir que ce
rostre picker il est pas très très long
non plus mais ils avaient quand même
l'appareillage pour pomper du sang et ça
c'est quand même vachement intéressant
vous voyez il y a même deux petites
dents là au bout de deux petits crochets
euh au bout de son son rostre picker là
c'est assez effrayant pour dire les
choses comme je les pense voyez ces deux
crochets là qui sont redessinés ici donc
bref c'est ils avaient quand même cet
appareillage et donc tout se passe comme
si ce moustique en fait du Crétacé avait
appartenait en fait si vous voulez à un
morphotype où en fait les mâles
n'étaient pas encore super distingués
des femelles comme le sont les
moustiques modernes et ça c'est très
intéressant ça veut dire que c'est un
peu une réminiscence en fait du plan
anatomique ancestr des moustiques où
mâles et femelle devaient tous les deux
avoir des rosre piiqueer et c'est
seulement après en fait que le le rosre
piiqueur a été perdu chez les mâles et
alors ce qui suggère c'est ce qu'il
suggère en plus dans cet article c'est
que comme il y a encore quelques rares
espèces de moustiques aujourd'hui qui
ont encore des mâles avec des rostre
piiqueers ce qu'il suggère dans cet
article c'est que peut-être même c'est
arrivé plusieurs fois au cours de
l'évolution des moustiques cette cette
perte du rostre piqueer chez les mâles
et d'ailleurs au passage on soulignera
la présence du français André nel parmi
les auteurs donc on lui souhaite nos
félicitations on entre maintenant dans
la deuxème partie de cette vidéo on va
se faire un petit bestof des news de
2023 parce que évidemment c'est la fin
de l'année donc on va se faire un petit
récapitulatif des grandes découvertes ou
des découvertes les plus surprenantes
qui ont été faites cette année et la
première que je voulais vous repartager
c'est évidemment la découverte de
vielasia euh dans les les phosphorides
du kersy vielasia qui est donc une
nouvelle espèce de chauve-souris des
découverte dans le Kery en France et qui
résout pas mal de questions sur
l'origine des kiropteres des des
questions qu'on se posait sur l'origine
des kiropteres donc j'en ai fait une
vidéo à part entière qui s'appelle
l'évolution des chauve-souris tout
simplement donc si vous voulez savoir ce
que nous apporte vielasia sur
l'évolution des chauves-souris allez
voir cette vidéo mais en gros euh
vielasia euh et la phylogénie qui a
découlé de l'étude de vielasia surtout
euh nous montre quand lesé colocation
est apparu au sein des chauve-souris
nous montre que les premières
chauve-souris pouvaient voler mais
n'avaient pas encore décolocation ou
décolocalisation si vous
préférez donc c'est c'est c'est un
fossile qui est très très intéressant
qui est très très bien préservé qui nous
vient des phosphorides du Kery vous
pouvez aller voir cette vidéo évidemment
toutes les vidéos que je vais vous
présenter maintenant je les ai mises en
dans la section dans la section
description pour que vous puissiez aller
les voir si vous les avez raté dans la
section what the fuck les idées et les
découvertes les plus surprenantes qui
ont été faites cette année on a
évidemment le T-Rex malin comme un singe
issu d'un
article d'un article qui a été publié au
début de l'année dernière et qui nous
disait en fait que bah les les
tyrannosaures avaient autant de neurones
que des
chimpanzés en se basant sur la taille du
cerveau des tyrannosaures le cerveau des
tyrannosaures est suffisamment gros pour
avoir contenu autant de neurones que
celui d'un chimpanzé du coup les
tyrannosaures devaient être quand même
super intelligents euh et évidemment
tout ça appliqué à la taille de cerveau
de plein de dinosaures comparant donc
les dinosaures à des différentes espèces
de singes suggérant ainsi par la même
que évidemment ces dinosaures étaient
étaient d'une intelligence tout à fait
remarquable oui mais cela ne marche que
si le nombre de neurones est directement
corrélé à l'intelligence or étant donné
le nombre de neurones qui a dans le
cerveau d'une baleine et c'est ce que
j'avais fait remarquer dans la vidéo bah
les baleines devraient être vachement
plus intelligentes que nous le le fait
est que voilà si sachant qu' en plus les
signes d'intelligence on les voit bien
chez les dauphins par exemple euh bon
bah les baleines qui ont des cerveaux
beaucoup plus gros que les dauphins donc
beaucoup plus de neurones que les
dauphins on devrait voir des signes
d'intelligence beaucoup plus évidents
que chez les dauphins et le nombre de de
neurones étant beaucoup plus élevé chez
les baleines que chez l' humain
notamment les baleines bleues ou les
cachalot par exemple qui ont des
cerveaux qui peuvent atteindre 9 10 kg
bon bah normalement le leur intelligence
devrait pas faire un pli voilà et on est
toujours en train de débattre sur
sont-elles réellement intelligents ou
pas intelligent ou pas ces baleines bon
donc c'est c'est c'était juste pour
souligner que faire le raccourci entre
nombre de neurones et intelligence bah
c'est un raccourci quoi voilà c'est tout
et donc c'est ce que la comparaison ici
vous voyez entre le cerveau de ses
dinosaures et celui de ses primates elle
fait ce raccourci là entre nombre de
neurones et intelligence non le nombre
de neurones n'est pas directement lié à
l'intelligence certes ça va jouer un
rôle on est d'accord mais ce n'est pas
lié à l'intelligence et surtout il faut
considérer encore une fois le poids on
ne s'attend pas à ce qu'un gros animal
est autre chose que des gros organes y
compris un gros cerveau donc tout ça
tout ça ça a formé la base d'un article
qui a été très décrié je vous invite à
aller voir voir le palaleéo news en
question pour en entendre plus plus
parler il y avait eu aussi du coup le
dleosteus euh en début d'année le
dunclleosteus qui avait rétréci un grand
coup hein euh le le fameux dunleosteus
de 8 9 m qu'on a l'habitude de voir dans
les documentaires et dans les films les
films d'horreur à petit budget euh pas
très beau ou bien ou bien d'autres hein
donc ce ce d'Unus d'uncléostéus de 8 9 m
et bien cet article nous apprenait
que bah en fait cette estimation de
taille elle sortait du cul elle sortait
de nulle part aussi c'était une
estimation au pipomètre voilà au doigts
mouillés comme on dit et que en faisant
en faisant des maths des vrais de la
bonne science et ben en réalité la
taille de dunclleosteus elle
tombait presque invariablement à
seulement 3 4 m 5 m grand
maximum donc ça vous fait rétrécir le
dleéostéus un grand coup donc voilà si
ça ça vous intéresse particulièrement si
vous êtes Paléo artiste si ça vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à aller voir ce
Paleo news qui parle de
dunleosteus de même si vous êtes pas les
haut artistes dans la même vidéo on
avait tous vos Raptors sont faux voilà
le le chapitre de la vidéo intitulé ici
tous vos Raptors sont faux euh nous
Rappelz encore une fois que dans les
documentaires dans les films et cetera
il manque toujours un petit bout de pot
ici entre l'épaule et le poignet donc
entre l'épaule et le poignet il est
censé y avoir normalement un bout de
peau che chez les droméosauridés qui
s'appelle le
propatagium et pourtant ce bout de poau
était préservé depuis le début chez
Microraptor par exemple donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on sait depuis les
années 2000 mais pourtant c'était passé
complètement inaperçu et c'est un
article de 2023 qui nous l'a rappelé
donc chapeau chapeau euh et enfin
toujours pour les paléoartistes nous
sommes dans la section paléoartistes euh
les lèvres chez les dinosaures on a eu
un article qui prétendait nous ramener
la preuve que les tyrannosauridés donc
tous les théropodes devaient avoir des
lèvres mais dans cet article c'était un
peu la douche froide parce qu'on
découvrait que la preuve en question
enfin les preuves en question c'était en
fait une preuve une unique preuve sous
la forme d'une seule et unique dent et
parce que la dent en question était pas
usée ça voulait dire qu'ils avaient des
lèvres c'est léger et dans cette vidéo
je rappelle une règle fondamament mental
qui est que tant qu'on aura pas
découvert de tissu momifié de lèvres de
dinosaure alors ça restera plus
parsimonieux et donc plus
scientifique de reconstituer vos
dinosaures sans lèvres parce que tant
qu'on a pas la preuve de l'existence
d'un organe c'est mieux de considérer
que l'organe en question n'existait pas
rassurez-vous ce n'est pas plus
scientifique de mettre des lèvres à vos
dinosaures contrairement à ce que tout
tweeter a décidé de vous faire croire
dans la catégorie tu croyais que c'était
évident alors qu'en fait non ça l'était
pas l'extinction permient Trias et le
volcanisme sibérien Encore un grand
classique des documentaires le lien
entre l'extinction permient Trias et le
volcanisme de Sibérie il est direct
quand on parle des faunes d'invertébré
parce que bah vous avez le volcanisme
sibérien et les faunes d'invertébré à la
limite permiatrias là où elles sont le
mieux préservé c'est en Chine donc c'est
juste à côté donc là on avait les dépôts
volcaniques qui montraient que oui le
volcanisme et l'extinction avaient au
moins lieu en même temps bon corrélation
n'est pas causalité on entend bien mais
vu les dégâts enfin vu la quantité de
magma qui a été produite pendant le le
volcanisme sibérien ce serait quand même
étonnant que ça ait eu aucun effet quoi
mais quand on vous montrait des
listrosaurus par exemple enfin quand on
vous montrait des thrapsides
sud-afriquain succombé à ce à ce
volcanisme donc notamment des
listrosaurus par exemple et ben ça par
contre c'était un gros raccourci parce
qu'en réalité on avait aucune preuve
jusqu'à présent que le volcanisme
sibérien avait eu des séquence sur les
faunes sud-africaines là où on trouve
les listrosaurus il n'y a pas de
listrosaurus en Russie il a il y a des
faunes de thapside en Russie mais il y a
pas de listrosaurus et de toute façon la
la limite permientrias n'est pas
préservée en Russie donc on n pas ces on
n pas cet intervalle de temps qui
correspond à la crise biologique en
Russie en Afrique du Sud on l'a mais on
avait aucune preuve que ce volcanisme
avait eu des effets direct sur la faune
en Afrique du Sud maintenant ces choses
faites depuis 2023 avec avec un pic de
mercure qui a été découvert dans le
carou en Afrique du Sud pic de mercure
qui a lieu pile au moment de du du grand
changement phonique qui a lieu à la fin
du Permien donc la crise biologique donc
ce pic de mercure c'est du mercure qui
est on le pense envoyé par les volcans
parce que de toute façon du mercure ça
se balade pas comme ça il faut au moins
qu'il a du volcanisme pour pour qu'il se
disperse dans l'atmosphère et retombe
aussi loin que ça de du volcanisme parce
que l'Afrique du Sud elle était pas loin
du Pôle Sud à l'époque donc pour que du
mercure se se dépose à cet endroit-là
alors qu'il y a aucune source de mercure
à proximité c'est qu'il y a fallu un
volcanisme balaise genre le volcanisme
des traps de Sibérie et puis les
nouvelles de l'évolution humaine
évidemment la vidéo qui a fait râer mais
alors tellement et alors du coup je la
remets j'en remets encore un coup odzi
qui change de visage he les analyses
génétiques d'Ozi qui montrent qu'il
avait la peau quand même vachement plus
foncée que qu'on croyait allez voir la
vidéo si vous voulez en savoir plus
c'est tout expliqué mais bon moi c'est
c'est une des c'est un des palaleon news
qui a eu le plus de vues donc je ne
pouvais pas ne pas en reparler ça ça a
tellement fait raller les gens que
c'était c'était juste jouissif dans le
même épisode on avait aussi Paranthropus
la découverte de protéines dans les EAU
DE Paranthropus qui en soit nous
apprenait rien de nouveau mais c'est
juste la première fois qu'on découvre
des protéines préservées dans des
ossements domininé de plusieurs millions
d'années des protéines préservées dans
des osements domininés de de plusieurs
millions d'années rien que ça
normalement ça doit vous filer un
orgasme c'est ça ça ça ouvre les portes
de la paléogénétique à la
paléanthropologie euh des homininés très
anciens Paranthropus australopiecus on
va pouvoir découvrir des choses qu'on
s'imaginait même pas pouvoir savoir j'ai
pas eu une nouvelle depuis mais je suis
certain que ça va que ça va donner des
choses super intéressantes dans les
années à venir et pour finir un
documentaire qui nous annonce des
découvertes alors même que ça n'a pas
encore été publié dans les revues à
comité de lecture comme ça la bouclée
bouclée avec le pliosaur du début de la
vidéo euh cave of bones la la grotte aux
osmans le le documentaire sur omomon
ladyady qui soi-disant aurait enterré
ses morts mais comme je l'avais déjà
rappelé dans ma vidéo sur le sujet et
qui s'affiche en ce moment à l'écran le
le il y a toujours rien qui a été
accepté pour publication alors oui les
publications sont là sur le site de eife
mais ce sont encore des préprints ça
veut dire que il y a des commentaires
qui ont été faits par des relecteurs des
des pairres hein d'autres scientifiques
qui ne sont pas du tout satisfaits avec
ce qui est dit dans ces publications
donc les publications sont pas encore
finalisé donc il y a pas de publication
voilà pour dire les choses simplement si
à si eife n'avait pas décidé de produire
des préprint vous n'auriez pas de
publication du tout voilà donc vous ne
seriez même pas au courant en réalité et
pour ceux qui ne sauraient pas de quoi
je parle ce documentaire ce qu'il
propose c'est que homonaledi enterrait
ses morts et produisait de l'art et
faisait du feu et cetera et cetera bref
que homonaledi avait un système cognitif
qui était équivalent à celui d'Homo
sapiens ou l'homme de Néandertal mais
avec un cerveau qui fait la moitié de
leur
taille et les preuves sont vraiment très
très mal étayé elles sont très très mal
étayées et ça par contre ça a été
confirmé par une publication récente
dans Journal of human evolution donc par
des experts dans le domaine qui ont fait
une publication qui basiquement résume
l'argumentaire que j'ai donné moi dans
ma vidéo hein donc que les preuves sont
pas là que c'estes traits que qui
sidentifie comme étant fait par des
hininés en réalité c'est de la c'est de
l'usure naturelle de la dolomie qui crée
un pattern en en pot d'éléphant donc
c'est pas du tout c'est pas forcément
c'est pas parce que ça a l'air
artificiel que ça les forcément en gros
bref euh ils reviennent sur exactement
tous les arguments que que que j'ai
abordé dans mon dans ma vidéo et même un
petit peu plus donc je vous invite à
aller voir cette publication
scientifique qui elle a été acceptée et
a été publiée donc pour l'instant on a
pas plus de nouvelles que ça de la part
de l'équipe de le burger concernant ce
ce documentaire et les découvertes
associées on espère que la revue des
articles en question va finir par se
faire en attendant bah on a on a
toujours les voilà les préprint c'est ce
que je vous disais c'est toujours en
préprint avec un avis de eife écrit ici
inadéquate voilà c'était Palo news je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'ancien et je vous dis à très
[Musique]
bientôt